hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in part two of his proma to any
future metaphysics a Manu K from about
section 18 through section 21 is going
to be elaborating for us a really really
Central distinction and we could say
also a process and understanding this I
think for many people can kind of fill
in the gaps when they're confused about
what is Kant actually trying to tell us
about how the mind works all this stuff
later on about Concepts and categories
how does this play out and so the place
to begin is with his discussion about
experience and the empirical so he says
well all judgments of experience are
empirical they have their ground and
immediate sense perception all empirical
judgments are not therefore judgments of
experience he says besides the empirical
and in general besides what is given to
sensuous intuition special Concepts must
be super added and so we're going to
talk about the role these play Concepts
which have their origin quite a priori
in the
pure understanding right so let's take a
look at that special Concepts
bizra Concepts that that are performing
a particular role I mean kind of a
universal role too originally generated
in the understanding
in so sprungli you know this original
rising up from within the understanding
and you know is there an answer to where
these came from or why they're there not
at this point and in a certain sense we
just have to sort of take this on but
we're going to find out that there are a
number
of right concepts of the understanding
that are going to be playing this
essential role these are things that get
added in as he says or get imposed so he
says um under which every perception
must first be all of all subsumed and
then by their means changed into
experience so not everything that we
experience in one sense of the term
counts as
experience in a second more technical
sense of the term so he tells us
empirical judgment ments if they have
objective validity are what Kant is
going to call judgments of
experience so is uh judgment
right is the word for experience what it
is that we we go through you might say
so he says those which are only
subjectively valid I name mere judgments
of
perception so again you see that term
judgment right
and is perception literally taking the
truth of something but he doesn't mean
it in that sense because we can be
mistaken about it sort of perceiving it
as true right and so judgments of
perception are not the same thing as
judgments of experience whereas for some
philosophers maybe they are and K would
say Well they're they're actually
mistaken so how are these different from
each other we've already been told one
main differentiator these are
subjectively valid gig right they they
are uh working for they are
acceptable they count we could say but
only subjectively only for one person or
a bunch of people but not for all human
beings in
general over on the other side judgments
of experience these are are as he says
objectively valid that means that they
work they apply for everybody for all
human beings now you can say well what
if somebody gets a judgment wrong that's
supposed to be objectively valid well
you can point out to them that they've
got it wrong right whereas with
subjective judgments of
perception H not quite so easy some of
these maybe it really does depend on you
know where we are you know got some
examples of these later on the room is
warm sugar sweet wormwood nasty wormwood
is a thing that was used in medicinals
and it's got a kind of bitter taste to
it
right and he says you know I don't
expect or that I or any other person
shall always find it as I now do each of
these sentences only expresses a
reference of two Sensations to the same
subject myself and that only in my
present state state of perception so I
could taste some sugar and be like the
sugar isn't sweet today somebody could
be like well it's cuz it's salt buddy or
baking soda but it could be sugar and my
my you know taste
gustatory uh apparatus could not be
working right or something's going wrong
somewhere right there's all sorts of
things possible in that respect when we
say that something is a judgment of
experience we're saying it is
objectively valid it holds for everybody
um a little bit later he's going to say
objective validity and necessary
Universal validity for everybody are
equivalent
Concepts right um so when we consider a
judgment universally valid and hence
necessary we understand it to have
objective validity so we've got these
these two right what's what else is
different between them well coming back
to 18 he says that judgments of
perception don't require a pure concept
of the understanding but only the
logical connection of perception in a
thinking subject now The Logical there
don't think in terms of like the
discipline of logic and you're doing
arguments or something like that it's
much
simpler what he means is you're
connecting two things together the room
is warm right you're making a judgment
these two things that you're perceiving
you're connecting them together in that
judgment and so logical connections of
perception he also talks about uh
representation that is
for of sensuous Zena intuition an and so
anybody who's worked through the first
part is already familiar with all of
these
terms if we want to get to judgments of
experience we've got to add something he
says now he says all of our judgments
are at first merely judgments of
perception they hold good only for us
and we do not till afterwards give them
a new reference to an object and we want
that they shall always hold good for us
and in the same way for everybody else
but we're often mistaken if we're going
just by judgments of perception how do
we get there though how can we get
Universal validity he says there's no
reason for the judgments of other men
necessarily to agree with mine if it
were not the unity of the object to
which they all refer and with which they
Accord so they must agree with one
another if we want to have going back to
the topic of this part if we want to
have a
universal
necessary pure Natural
Science it's got to be stuff of our
experiential
world that we can make judgments about
that that do
apply OB objectively universally
necessarily for everybody and that that
is in fact what we are asserting in this
right how do we get there so he says
with all objects of sense judgments of
experience take their objective validity
not from the immediate cognition of the
object the perception that we begin with
but merely from the condition of the
universal validity of empirical
judgments which never rests upon
empirical or sensuous conditions but
upon a pure concept of the understanding
the object in itself always remains
unknown but when by the concept of the
understanding the connection of the
representations of the object which are
given to the object by our sensibility
is determined as universally valid the
object is determined by this right so he
says um what experience teaches es me
under certain certain circumstances it
must always teach me and everybody its
validity is not limited to the subject
or to its state at a particular time so
when I say for example the ear is
elastic this judgment is yet a judgment
of perception only I do nothing but
refer two Sensations in my senses to one
another but if I want to make it a
judgment of
experience I have to have this stand
under a condition which makes it
universally valid that's what these
Concepts coming from the understanding
are actually doing they are giving that
Universal validity to it not by drawing
upon experience but by using the
judgments of experience and working on
them in a different way bringing
something new to the to the picture
right and so this is actually going to
give
us um a train transition from my own
Consciousness to as he calls it
Consciousness in general
b u anybody's Consciousness my
consciousness of this should be the same
as your Consciousness not in the
specific perceptions that we have but in
the concept of the understanding that's
the same in you as it is in me and
everybody else this is one of the key
contributions that KH is making through
his philosophy right so you know in 20
he says we have to analyze experience
and general and see what is contained in
this product of the senses and of the
understanding which then gives us the
Judgment of experience itself as
possible says the foundation is the
intuition of which I become conscious
the perception which belongs to the
senses then judging takes place which
happens by the understanding right and
this judging can be two different kinds
can be judging that remains just with
the perception and Compares them with
each other you know is this spot over
here red uh when I put the worm on the
fish hook did I actually get the hook
through the worm pick whatever you want
right but if we want to go beyond that
then we have to rely on these concepts
of the understanding and we do that when
we judge he says that um here we go um
when perception becomes experience the
intuition must be subsumed under a
concept which determines the form of
judging in general with regard to the
intuition connects the empirical
consciousness of the intuition and
Consciousness in general so we get this
important transition and thereby
procures Universal validity for
empirical judgments he says a concept of
this nature is a pure a priori concept
of the understanding which does nothing
but determine for an intuition the
general way in which it can be used for
judging and so what's an example of this
cause he says let the concept be that of
cause then it determines the intuition
which is subsumed under it that of air
with regard to judging in general the
concept of air as regards its expansion
serves in the relation of antecedent to
consequent in a hypothetical judgment
therefore we can go to judgments of
experience that have to do with air
right but we're using a concept coming
from the understanding a pure concept of
causality which we're going to see is
only one of many that we could in fact
be using so he says this is you know
sort of summing things up uh before a
judgment of perception can be become a
judgment of experience the perception
should be subsumed under some concept of
the understanding and then he says if
all of our synthetic judgments are
analyzed in so far as they are
objectively valid that is in so far as
they are judgments of experience and not
merely of perception they never consist
of mere intuitions connected only by
comparison into a judgment but they
would be impossible if it were not a
pure concept of the understanding super
added to the concepts abstracted from
intuition so he says even in the
judgments of pure mathematics this holds
as well so then in 21 he's going to say
uh to prove the possibility of
experience so far as it rests on pure op
prior concepts of the understanding we
have to represent what belongs to
judgments in general and the various
moments of understanding in them and
this is where we're get going to get to
a sort of schema a table that Kant will
provide us with and this is where we get
to the you know the famous uh categories
and and various types of
organizing
these a priori pure concepts of the
understanding that Kant takes all of us
to have and says that he has you know
finally in terms of you know
philosophy's progress analyzed and
placed before us so so we get this very
important transition here from judgments
of perception to judgments of experience
through the super addition or
application of these special Concepts
originally arising out of the
understanding